ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
นะคะวันนี้ฉันนี่วันอะเรียนภาษาไทยวัน
อาทิตย์ค่ะวันอาทิตย์ครูเตรียมจะเขียน
หรือให้กูเอมี่ปฏิทินอ๋อ
เดี๋ยวเรียมเขียนคูเรียร์มาเขียนใช่ค่ะ
เขียน
วันนี้เป็นวันอะไรนะคะคุณเอ๋วันอาทิตย์
วันอาทิตย์
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันอาทิตย์ที่
19 ค่ะอ๋อ
19 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนอาวาคมฮือ
ธันวาคม
ปีคศอะไรคะ
2021 ค่ะ
2021 แล้วปีพตอะไรคะ 2,000
564 ค่ะโง่
2564 ใช่วันนี้เป็นวันอาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์
ที่ 19 เดือนธันวาคม
ค่ะปีพศ.ปีคศพ.ศ 2020 เอ็ดปีคศ
พศผช
2564 ค่ะครูเรียมตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอน
นี้เวลานี้
และขอขอบคุณเรียมดูดูอะไรคะดูอะไรดู
นาฬิกาค่ะนาฬิกา
นาฬิกาเวลา
5 โมง
ใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
5 วง 53 นะคะ
คุกคูเรียมคลิปนี้
เป็นคลิปที่
10  9  9  7  9 หรอค่ะครูเอกกับผู้เดียว
ม.คผู้
ใต้ๆ
สำหรับปี
2021 เนาะชัยค่ะ
2021 ครูเรียมกับครูเอ๋ต้องสอนนักเรียน
20 คลิปนะคะอ่ะที่ชัยนาทสิบเก้าแล้ว
ใช่แล้วแล้วก็จะเปลี่ยนปีนะคะเด็กอีกคลิป
นึงก็ 20 นะคะ
ใช่ค่ะคุณเรียมคะปีนี้
ตี 5 ปีหน้า
2022 ใช่ค่ะปีหน้าก็จะเป็น
2022  2 นะคะ
2022 ด้วยอ่ะคนไทยมากๆใช่มะเวลาปีเก่า
แล้วก็เปลี่ยนปีใหม่
ใช่ค่ะคนไทยชอบ
ไปไปไปหา
หาหา
อะไรค่ะหาหมอพี่ขอดู
หนูหมอหมอดูน่ะไม่ใช่ไม่สบายแล้วคุณหมอ
หมอดูไม่ใช่นะคะหมอดูเนี่ยก็จะมีหมอดูไทย
หมอดูไทยจีนผู้เหวสะกิดนิดนึงนะคะได้สัก
ครู่นะคะรอแป๊บนึง
เดี๋ยวกูเอหา screen  a ก่อนนะคะ
ไปหาหมอดู
ไปหานี่อะโอเค
อย่างนี้ครับครูเรียนแป๊บๆ
นี่หาดูเอง
ขอบคุณค่ะเจอแล้วปากกาปากกา
หมอดูเนี่ยเป็นผู้ 1 นายก็ได้ค่ะครูเรียม
บางทีเป็นผู้ชายบางทีเป็นผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิง
ก็เมื่อกี้กูแอบพูดอันนี้คนไทย
ครูเอ๋นะไทยจีน
คนไทยคนไทยไทยนะคะหมอดูมีหมอดูไทยหมอดู
ไทยจีน
on วันนี้จะพูดหมอดูไทยหมอดูเนี่ยเขาจะ
ดูแล้วบ่โอ้
[เพลง]
คุณจะดีดี
หรือไม่ดี
งานหรือไม่แต่งงาน
หมอดู
แต่ว่าวันนี้เราจะพูดเบาะหมอดูเบอร์
ดูมือให้กูดีมาเลยใช่ไหมคะเดี๋ยวเรา
เดี๋ยวเรามาใกล้ๆกันนะชายสกรีนไปหมอดู
เนี่ยจะจะดูมือ
มือเข็มชัดเนาะคุณเรียมเห็นตรงนี้ไหมคะมี
เส้น
เล่นเรียกว่าเส้นอะไรคะเส้นลายมือ
หมอ
เป็นไรอยู่ทำไมลายมือครูเรียนกับกูเอก
คล้ายๆกันใครๆกันให้
พอๆๆ
น่าใช้มาก
ใช่ทำไม
มือเปลี่ยนเมืองอำเภอขึ้นมาดู
ดูเส้นเส้นอะไรจะไปหา
ก็เป็นลายมือเส้นในมือก็จะมีคู่เรียงก็จะ
มีเส้นเส้นที่เส้นที่ 1 เป็นหนี
เส้นที่ 2
ค่ะเป็นนี้เป็นที่ 2 อ๋อ
แล้วก็เส้นที่ 3
[เพลง]
จะมีเส้นใหญ่ๆอุ้ยหายไปไหนผู้เรียน
โอเคโอเคค่ะพี่เอ๋น่ะคูเรียมหายไป 3
นี้นะคะ 3 เส้นอาจจะบางคนอาจจะมี 4 เส้น
ตรงนี้อ่ะโง่ครูเรียมอ่ามือเนี่ยมีมือขวา
กับมือซ้าย
ใช่มั้ยอ่าฝั่งนี้เมื่อขวา
โอเคมั้ย
ใช่ขวาแล้วก็มือซ้าย
สาย
ผู้หญิงนะดูหน่อยซ้าย
[เพลง]
ครับผู้ชายดูมาขวา
โอ้ว
เรียมเป็นผู้หญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเต้าอยู่
ซ้ายมือสหายซ้ายอ่ะเรียมดูของเรียมนะคะ
คู๋ให้นักเรียนดูของครูเอ๋เส้นนี้ราคา
เส้นก็เส้นที่ 1 ค่ะเส้นที่ 1
ตัวเองแค่สกรีน
ไปไหน
ลบตัวนี้นะคะครูเอ๋วาดว่า
นี่เป็นนิ้วโป้งนี้เห้ยเร็วเอาใหม่
ต้องสูง
นิ้วโป้งนิ้วชี้
นิ้วกลาง
นิ้วนางนิ้วก้อย
นะคะแล้วก็ข้อมือ
มันเป็นเบอร์มือ
cm ที่ 1 คูเรียมชอบสีอะไรคะชอบสีเขียว
มีสีเขียวคุยให้สีเขียวเป็นเส้นที่ 1
เป็นที่ 155
cm ที่ 1 เส้นที่ 1 เนี่ยเป็นเส้นอายุ
โคเรียม
โง่
เป็นเส้นอายุถ้าเส้นนะเขาบอกเส้นชัด
เส้นชัดฉันแบบเนี้ยชัดเว้ย
เล่นชัด
[เพลง]
เป็นใหญ่ๆ
เป็นชัดหาอา
ฉันก็บอกว่าดีหรือไม่ดีคะ D  D  D อายุ
เท่าเส้นมาถึงนี่อูร์อายุ 1  120 ปี
โอ้โห้โย้โห้โอเคมั้ย
120 ปีโอเคไหมครูเรียมโอ้วโห
ไม่เอาล่ะ
ไม่รู้
ครูเอกก็คิดก็ไม่เอากูเอกคิด
60 ปีโอเค
60  70
โอเค
แอบถ้าครูเอ๋
120 ปีแล้วแข็งแรงคะโอเคแข็งแรงโอเคเออ
แต่ว่าถ้าไม่แข็งแรงไม่โอเค
เส้นชีวิตหน้าครูเรียมถ้าเขาบอกว่าถ้ามี
อะไรตัด
เนี้ยจะไม่สบายอ่ะ
จะ
มีไหมดูของคุยก็ได้เดี๋ยวกูเองสต๊อกสกรีน
หรือนี่เห็นไหมกูเอ๋มีมากๆมีต้องเรียบผัก
มีตัดตัดตัด
ใช่มีเยอะๆเนี่ยมีเม็ดอะ
ไม่สบายบ่อยๆๆพูดเล่นเส้นของเรียมไม่ชัด
คิดว่าแสงวันไม่ชัดเอามันต่อแล้วโอเคอ่ะ
ไม่ๆๆอ๋อมีตัดเหมือนกันทุเรียนจริงๆเรียน
ก็ไปๆกูอะมีเส้นนิด
เอามีเส้นนี้ใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่เนี่ยเป็นหยัง
น้ออ้าย
ไม่สบายดี
บ่มีบ่มีไหมพี่ไม่สบายแต่โอร่า
บางคนพูดโอเคดีหมื่นบางคนบอกไม่สบาย
เนี่ยก็ครูเอกก็ไม่สบายบ่อยๆนะคะ
อันนี้เป็นเส้นชีวิตของครูเรียมในดูใหม่
นี่
เกาะยาวนะยาวถึงที่นี่
โอเคกูเรียม 120 ปีโอเค
แข็งแรงโอเคแข็งแรงแข็งแรง
นะอันนี้เป็นที่หนึ่งนะคะ
เส้นที่ 2 คู่เรียม
เส้นที่สองเส้นนี้
เส้นนี้
ใช่
เอกว่าให้
นี่
คืออะไรคะเส้นที่ 2 เขาบอกเอาสีอะไรค่ะ
ครูเรียมสีชมพูสีชมพูได้นะ French ที่สอง
สีชมพูคู๋วัดไม่เรียบร้อย
สีชมพู
อุ้ยขอโทษค่ะจะกู้นะคะ
เซนต์ที่ 2
สี 2 สีชมพูโมสีชมพูพื้น
คืออะไร
Big  Cock
ik  Q
O
เอออ่ะ
มีเส้นเลอ
[เพลง]
ขอเส้นถึงโอ๋ 2 คู่เรียมเส้นเส้นถึงตรง
นี้เลยเนี่ยตรงนี้เลย
จัดทุเรียนดูดีๆแต่มันเล็กๆอ๋ออ๋อเล็กๆ
เตรียมโอเคนะเพราะว่ารู้เส้นเส้นของครู
เรียม 1 เส้นใช่ไหมไอคิวใช่ค่ะ 1 เส้นดี
มากครูเอ๋
กูเองเป็นแบบนี้
เห็นไหมฮะอ๋อ
สองสาม
คืออะไรคะครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋
ถ้าหนึ่งเส้นใช่ไหม 1 เส้นหน่ะเวลา
โคเรียมคิดอ่านหนังสือทุเรียนก็ถ้า
มีหนังสือ
อ่านหนังสือจนเสร็จใช้ไหมคะค่ะแต่ครูเอ๋
หน้าแพะคิดอ่านหนังสืออ่านหนังสือหนึ่ง
ไม่ได้
ผู้เหงต้อง YouTube ดู YouTube
อ่านหนังสือเราก็มี
อยู่ที่นี่เดี๋ยวนะคะเอกก็มีโทรศัพท์
เบอร์
โทรศัพท์
มีพลคะจึงคิดว่าครูเอกเก่งมากๆ
ไม่ไปเก่งเก๋
[เพลง]
มีอะไรดีคู๋เปิดเพลงฟัง
คู่เอกก็จะอ่านหนังสือแล้วก็
ตั้งเพลงหรอคะ
รอสักครู่เราพูดห้าสี่สามสองหนึ่ง
โอเค
เอกก็จะ
ทาน
เราตัวเอกก็ดู YouTube ด้วยใช่
กูเองคิดว่าครูเอกเก่ง
บ้าบ่ๆๆ
นะคะอ่านหนังสือหรือ 1 อย่างนอนหลับคู๋
ต้องอ่านหนังสือหรือดู YouTube ฟังเพลง
บางทีมี YouTube  2 เปิด YouTube ดู
ซีรีส์เปิด YouTube ฟังเพลงแล้วก็อ่าน
หนังสือ
โห
นักเรียน
ทำหลายๆอย่างเหมือนครูเอ๋ได้ไหมคะคิดว่า
นักเรียนไม่ได้เนาะนำเอาไว้ที่กูอีกละ
อ่านหนังสือ
ดู YouTube กินข้าว
เออ
ครูเอ๋อะไรนะอาบน้ำใช่ไหม
อาบน้ำเวลาอาบน้ำเนี่ยอ่ามีอันนี้มีแชมพู
แปรงฟันโอ้ยโอ้
นี่
บัญชีขอโทษนะคะ
อ่อนนักเรียนช็อคนิดหน่อยนะ
วันที่ 3
อันนี้โอเคบางทีครูเอ๋จะโอเคที่นี่ห้อง
น้ำ
ห้องน้ำ
เห็นนั่งที่นี่
อยากก็ที่นี่แชมป์ผมแล้วก็แชมพู
แล้วก็ที่นี่
แรงปันที่นี่พร่องน้ำแปรงฟันแชมพู
นักเรียน
ทำเหมือนครูเอ๋ไหมคะ
โอเคมั้ย
กู ah ทำหนึ่งอย่างไม่ได้
ก็ทำสองอย่าง
สองอย่าง 3 อย่าง
หนึ่งอย่างคุยนอนหลับรู้เองมีเวลานิด
เดียวหรอคะใช่เมื่อก่อนใช่ไหมเมื่อก่อนไป
ออฟฟิศมีเวลานิดหน่อยนอนตื่นก็แปรงฟันอาบ
น้ำห้องน้ำเวลา 5 นาที
5-10 นาที
เงิน
เสร็จงานเสร็จ 5-10 นาทีด้วยก็แปรงฟัน
แชมพู
ลายมือ
ลายมือครูเอ๋แบบนี้ไงเนี่ยลายมือแบบนี้
เนื้อ
ลายมือมีเส้นอาจ
มีเส้นแตกแตก 3 เส้น
อ๋อ
น่าจะแบบเบื่อเบื่อเบื่อ
อ่ะคะอ่านหนังสือเบื่อดูซีรีส์เบื่อฟัง
เพลงเบื่อแต่อ้าวอ่านหนังสือ
ดูซีรีส์ฟังเพลงโอเคไม่เบื่อ
คิดว่ารู๋เก่งไหมคะ
1 เส้นจะเก่งแบบคนที่มีเส้น 3 เส้นเนี่ย
ทำหนึ่งอย่างมันจะห้องมันจะเบื่อก็เลยไม่
เก่ง
โอเค
1 เส้นดีกว่าค่ะขอแบ่งเส้นแล้วก็ยาวดีนะ
คะ
หมอดูใช่ไหมคะหมอดูเชื่อ
หมอดูคลิป 1 เส้นอุ่นแล้วปะยาวดีค่ะเพิ่ง
เส้นต่อไปดีกว่าครูเลียม
เส้นที่ 3 เอาสีอะไรสีน้ำเงินค่ะตี
น้ำเงินเส้นที่ 3 อยู่ตรงนี้
อันนี้แต่ก็เค
เป็นเซตก็ได้ค่ะเส้นที่ 3 เนาะ
เส้นที่ 3 อะคูเอกรถตรงนี้ค่ะเส้นที่ 3
เส้นลายงูเส้นที่ 3 เรียกว่าเส้น
มีอะไรค่ะเส้นที่ 3 นะอันนี้เส้นที่ 2 ไอ
คิวใช่ไหมคะเส้นที่ 3 เส้น
เส้นเส้น
ความรักอา
เส้นความรัก
โหปิ้งด้วย
เป็นความรักเนี่ยครูเรียมคูเรียมต้องเอา
มือสองมือนะคะเดี๋ยวกูเองไอ้ๆยังไง
มึงเองจะเห็นแล้วแล้วมาต่อกัน
เห็นไหมเห็นไหม
เห็นค่ะของคุณเรียงผิด
คูณเลี่ยมส์มีแฟนหล่อ
หวู
จิงหรอคะเอาหมอดูบอกหมอดูบอก
จริงไม่จริงไม่รู้ไม่รู้ค่ะ 2 มือต่อกัน
แล้วก็อันนี้ซื้อ
เหมือนหรือเรือ
เรือเรือใช่ไหมคะหรือเรือ
ของคู่เรียมเป็นเรือสวย
เช้าสวยไหมสวย
ถ้าเป็นเรือแบบนี้ค่ะ
คู่เรียมสวยแฟนหล่อหมอ
ดูบอก
แต่ถ้าเส้นเป็นแบบนี้
ok  ok คือ
แบบ 5 เส้นแบบนี้
ต้องดูครูเรียนมือซ้ายใช่มั้ยมือสายมือ
ซ้ายเดี๋ยวกูเอาดูให้ใกล้ๆ
เมื่อขวาเริ่มต่อกันล่ะ
ซ้ายมือซ้ายมือซ้ายโคเรียมสวยเบอร์ขวาอะ
มือขวา
แฟนหล่อศ.เหมือนกันหมอเหมือนกัน
เวลาโคเรียมเดินแฟนเดินเดินด้วยเงินทุกคน
เห็นผู้หญิงสวยผู้หญิงนี่หล่อๆ
คนคนคนเห็นก็พูดโอ้ผู้หญิงสวยผู้ชายหล่อ
แบบนะเว้ยไม่เหมือนกันบางทีผู้ชายหลอกมาก
กว่าบางทีผู้หญิงสวยมากกว่าอ่ะ
หล่อสวยเท่ากับเข้ากัน
ของครูเอ๋
จริงๆเอาจริงๆนะของครูเอ๋
ผู้ชายหล่อ
เรียมเรียมเห็นลายมือครูเอ๋
สวยเหมือนกันเหมือนกันแต่นี่มีนิดหน่อย
ที่ไม่เหมือนครูเอ๋เคยไปเหมาะหาหมอดูหมอ
ดูพูดโอ้แฟนหล่อ
โอเคผู้ชายหล่อกว่า
เอกโหลดไหมคะ
โอเคฮ่าๆๆๆ
[เพลง]
อ่าหล่อขอตอนนั้นตอนนั้นครูเอ๋แต่งงาน
หรือยังคะยังไม่มีแฟนขอให้มีครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋
นี่
คนเดียวคุณเอ๋คนเดียวแฟน
แวนน่ะไม่มี
คู่เอกหล่อหล่อหล่อที่ไหน
ครูเอกคิดนะหล่อเนี่ยสีแพนวูสีแทน
สูงมากๆจมูกโด่ง
เอกชอบ
อะไรนะชอบแบบเอ่อเหมือนใครคะเหมือนใคร
เหมือนไทยนะ
อันโตนิโอ Man  The  Last ถ้าเธอกูเอชอบ
อันโตนิโอแมนดารา Last
Toys  India
ชอบใครนะเมนอินแบล็คอ่ะ will  Switch  is
a คลิปหล่อ
เอกคลิปนะ
ลบกูออกแต่งงานผู้ ami แฟนรูป
088 มิสเตอร์ Japan
มิสเตอร์ Japan คู่เอกคลิปหมอดู
โกหก
หิวแทนไหมคะผิว
ขาว
ผิวผิวขาว
เออดั้งดั้งโด่งไหมคะหน้าโอเคพี่โด่งมาก
กว่าครูเอ๋มองแล้วสูงไหมคะ
สูงมากกว่าครูเอ๋นิดหน่อย
175 ได้นั้น
170 ประมาณ 75
นั่งเห็นไหม
สีดำ
สูงประมาณ
คู๋
สูง 153
หมอ
53a สูง
153 โอเคสูงกว่ากูเองคิดต้องตาโตๆแล้วตา
โตไหมคะ
เหมือนกัน
มี
คนไทยเรียกว่าตาอะไรคะ Happy
Party  Party
เอกก็คิด
ผิวสีแทนอยู่ที่ไหนป้าตูมอยู่ที่ไหนโอเค
แปล
คุณพ่อคุณแม่บอกรอ
หนูเตะ
ทุกๆคนบอกดูเอ๋ว่าหล่อนี้เอกก็โอเค
หล่อมั้ยหล่อๆ
เมื่อก่อนครูเอกคิดไม่หล่อแต่ใจดีขอ
ใจดีคิดคลิปๆ B
โอเค
ไอ้หลอกไม่เป็นไรอ่ะเอ่อเออใช่ค่ะแต่ตอน
นี้แต่งงานนานๆ
หล่อเนาะ
นร.ๆตอนนี้คิดหล่อจังเลยอ่า
หมอดูบอกว่าถ้าเป็นเรือ
เรือแบบนะคะอาหาร 9 สวยๆหล่อๆขอ
[เพลง]
We  Are อันนี้จะหกสิบปี
แล้ว
ถ้ามีเส้น
มีเส้น
เช่นอันนี้จะบอกว่าแต่งงาน
อายุเท่าไหร่แต่ถ้านั้นๆแต่เต้นตึงๆ
มีไหมเดี๋ยว
ดูดู
ยังไง
ไม่เห็นน่ะ
ดูของครูเห็นจะเห็นไหมเห็นมากกว่า
กำมือกับมือ
แสงแสงหน้าใช่ๆมึงอ่ะไม่เป็นไรแสงโอเคแต่
กรรมมึง
โอเคครูเรียมแต่งงาน
ประมาณ
สิ่งไม่ติดไม่รู้นะ 60 ไว้หมอ
ประเมินอ่า
ประมาณสมัยหาของครูเรียมน่ะประมาณปีนี้ 29
ใช่ไหมใช้คำประมาณ 50% หน่อยๆ
ก็ประมาณ
30-35 คืนถึงไม่ชวนไงมันไกลไม่
ระมาณ
ไม่รู้
งงงง
ตู้ a  Do  Do อะไรดูเส้นนี้ไง
อยู่เส้นนิดเช่นนิดเส้นอ่าเห็นไหมค่ะของ
ครูเอ๋ของกูเออยู่ที่เนี่ยอ่ะอยู่ที่นี่
อันนี้ของกูเองอ่ะอ่ะจำ 50%  30 ปีของครู
อีกขึ้นมาข้างบน 40 กว่ากว่าขอเบอร์
กูเอนอ่ะแต่งงานอายุ 44
ว้าวคู๋นะ
แต่นั้นเป็นแฟนอายุตาม
ครูเอ๋อายุ 44 ปี
[เพลง]
แต่งงาน
เฮอเขาว่าที่นี่
คิดทุเรียนดูชัดๆ
เห็นมั้ย
อ๋อ
โหมึงใกล้ๆเห็นเห็นนะครัชมาก
หมอดูบอกครูเอ๋แต่งงานช้าช้าๆ
เรียงคิดว่าจะ
มีครูเห็นมีเส้นแบบไม่ชัวร์ตรงไหนอ่ะ
โอเคได้แต่งงานไม่ใหญ่มีเคโอเคไม่เป็นไร
ถ้ากูเรียนกับมึงอย่างนี้จะเห็น
หมีเห็นมั้ยมีมีมี
เฮถ้าไม่มีคนเดียวเออคนเดียวเธอเตรียมคน
เดียว
[เพลง]
นักเรียนจริงไม่จริงไม่รู้ไม่รู้นะคะแต่
ของครูเอ๋น่ะจริงแฟนหล่อ
ว่างาน 44
[เพลง]
ของเรียง
จริงหรือไม่จริงไม่รู้
ไม่รู้
ทุเรียนรอๆดู
รอดูนะคะ
ก็คนไทยคิดใช่ไหมอ่าปีหน้าดีไม่ดีแต่งงาน
ไม่แต่งงานก็ไปดู
ลายมือนะคะรวยไม่รวยแข็งแรงไม่แข็งแรงดู
ลายมือลายมือขอลายมือเปลี่ยนได้นะคะ
เปลี่ยนได้เปลี่ยนได้
ครูเอ๋รู้นิดหน่อย
เรียงไม่รู้
ที่ประเทศไทยมีผู้อันนี้ผู้หญิงผู้ชายดู
เป็นหมอดูมากๆเออมากๆฮะโอเคคนชื่อว่าหมอ
ดูลายมือหมอดูลายมือนะคะเมื่อก่อน
เมื่อก่อน
ครูเอ๋ชอบเช็คไลน์มือ
กูเอกก็เลยรู้นิดหน่อยอ๋อตอนนี้กูเห็นโต
โตคุยไม่เป็นไรไม่เอา
[เพลง]
นะคะไม่เป็นไรมือซ้ายอ่ะดูมือขวา
ตัวเองคิดเอง
โอเค
โอเคกลัวไม่เอานะคะใช่ค่ะ
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะดูเรียงก็โอเคถ้าไม่ดูก็
ไม่ฟังไม่ฟังอ่ะ
อ่าโอเคค่ะคลิปนี้หมดเวลาแล้ว
หมดเวลาแล้วค่ะนักเรียน
ใช่บ๊ายบายนะคะ
บายค่ะสวัสดีค่ะพี่เอกดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนได้บ้างบ๊ายบาย
[เพลง]